es geht um mord dorf mann aus der bronx
gespielt von jesse eisenberg der onkel
gespielt von steve carrell
ich bin br aber wenn ich mein bruder ist
also nachvollziehbar so was kann ich für
dich gut sekunde hallo
doch verdammt was onkel hat keine großen
bedürfnisse ihn einzustellen
er bahnt sich dann aber doch und gibt
seine sekretärin gespielt von kristen
stewart quasi als gouvernante und führer
durch die große welt von lasso anders an
seinen nerven
monika sikora ja das ist mein hobby
die beiden verlieben sich alles relativ
vorhersehbar das ist glaube ich keine so
gute idee
ich bin mir die männer zusammen die
leute können zwar nicht zusammen aber
oder nur vorübergehend oder die falschen
aber man hat mich den eindruck dass es
wirklich wichtig wäre es geht immer ums
ego wenn die ganze stadt in der sich von
ego es ist total nostalgie getrennt
allein in nostalgie eigentlich diese im
dekor stecken bleibt die innere
möglichkeiten sind ganz beschreibt hast
du keine lust auf mich ich bin so einsam
ich hatte mich schon gefreut hier zu
reden aber sogar dafür bin ich jetzt das
schönste an dem film ist eigentlich das
licht und in diesem fall führt es dazu
dass eine sowieso schon wunderbare
schauspielerin nämlich kristen stewart
hier noch wunderbar dass man ihnen das
schon mal gesagt sie haben diese reh im
scheinwerferlicht
die filme werden auch immer dünner
man hat das gefühl es irgendwann wird es
einfach so auslaufen sich aus lebendig
das ist natürlich für den einzelnen film
keine gute nachricht muss man sagen wie
der blitz zur der alte witze von woody
allen in den dialogen auf es hat aber
auch dann teilweise doch auch was
ranziger es ist immer wieder der alte
mann mit der jungen frau ehrlich sterben
mehr menschen am unerwiderter liebe
alterslos und insofern ist es eben der
jährliche das gut oder schlecht keine
antwort ist auch eine antwort